hello everybody and welcome back to the
amnesia custom story abduction all right
looking for something an orb or a piece
of glass nope just a tinderbox
oh wait what's it wait oh you can't slip
something past me oh yeah
I am observant like the dickens oh yeah
oh yeah give that
let me guess I got a run out of here
screaming uh uh I need oil
okay got it one bring it on ready for
you huh huh huh who wants some yeah yeah
no one yeah I bet no one I'm ready so
ready bring it on I'll bring it I'll
bring it I got a chair oh what's that
you want some chair Oh scooted you back
like a mile get out of here nope not
even a little bit close to me fo oh yeah
I'm the best better than the rest all
right we'll call it blue
blue all right come here
boink alright well that did that but I
still not have a key for the last place
did I miss a key somehow maybe yeah what
the hell did I miss a key oh and it
didn't I
boop balls well fine
um
what the hell okay the only places I
haven't been are in there and in that
top room up there
huh
I'm wondering if I'm just trying this
because I think I try to key on it but I
never check to see if it was actually
blocking okay yeah it was unlocked okay
my suspicions are right on the money
okay bring it on who wants some it's
stuck of course it is
Oh big open hallway not even a little
scary there we go I'm just closing the
door because not scared but for their
protection from me and my fists nothing
nothing what done Oh
Oh what was that that did not sound good
okay
useful hiding place ah tinderbox hello
monsters yeah goopy goop hello nope
nobody alright big open area perfect
place from monster ambush okay whatever
stores like oh wow okay it's a hidden
door somewhere in the upcoming Playa
Playa I was right could he really be
back
wait is this is this Daniel is am i
playing Daniel here huh doors lock need
to find a key in the West Wing okay huh
I really didn't expect this to be Daniel
I mean I know the mention of Alexander
but I did not think Daniel alright who's
here
more hiding places nothing a lot of
nothing um Wow yeah it's just big open
areas of nothing
humbly Hama Hama okay alright I pretty
much expect a monster like around every
corner
oh ha oh yeah ha ha
man I noticed these smallest details
then I mean that was that was pure luck
seriously guys I've never played this
before that was just luck
oh but I'm so great all right and where
was the grinding was it that locked door
that I came across before maybe uh who
knows these things
alright
nope nope no why do I even bother with
those things they never have anything in
them never never never
these two why why it's so tempting to
open them it's stuck
yes it is Oh oh hello more things to
smash sanity potion key gotcha
ah oh ah ah no get back I do not have
time for you I gotta open thee or get to
that secret door that opened up the
tablet more statues
don't try man
got a barrel smash I'll bring it on
making noise pollution did you leave I
don't hear any more music you got a
barrel look replace the barrel for a
chair now you're dead
ramming position ah
what up huh huh huh huh huh what was
that
my visions gone all wobbly okay whose
nothing it was nothing nothing at all
now I'm going to the room get it open
oh man then what was the grinding noise
uh oh wait no this is for here you get
sanity potion oh it's still wobbly come
on you had the sanity potion all right
leave Africa open up ha ha oh what the
hell oh oh come on books flying off the
shelf
Yeah right oh okay all right I like this
part of the whole place better because
it's not so much jump-scares oh oh oh as
a atmosphere well there's nothing in
here there's nothing in here why am I
here
to be like there should be a key or
something right right he's in there be
um oh here you go
crowbar what do I use this for it's this
my hiss is my key to the east side of
the place okay seriously there's nothing
else here right let me put it back off
you don't wanna do this I'll bring it
home Oh bring it ha
crowbar this crap crowbar nope um this
place is so big that I don't even know
if I've been in everything like
seriously
have I been here no no I don't know
all right i'ma backtrack a bit I've been
in there I'm gonna assume that I've been
in the door open places everyone could
be still oh here we go okay
boom oh you prove my strength
yeah nope I failed ah there we go as
looks good
I like this oil almost out of oil need
to use my tinderboxes okay that'll be my
hidey hole if torso oh oh I did not mean
to do that
a little waist can't see a damn thing
huh
trying to strike a match in between not
seeing a damn thing and wasting my oil
as I write this monster climb a door
vengeance burns in his heart lalala hit
me I was not fast enough
yeah but I am oh yeah dining honky ah ah
no no get out of here kid without here
wait did you just walk on by did you
just leave me alone oh you weren't even
real to begin with a few man fu okay I'm
out of here
that one knew its manners and knew to
leave me the [ __ ] alone oh yeah okay
moving on I just need one more red piece
then I can get out of here ladi Dadi
does Skippy skippy skip duty duty all
right
and got my crowbar finally a game that
lets me keep the crowbar after I break
it even in half-life
he lost his crowbar at some point okay
lots of chairs I guess they're arming me
up for a war going on oh hello Alexander
what's the dealio here you kind of stand
out from the rest of them Hall what's up
nothing
these porches you're like something
behind them
I don't know wait what the hell did I
just go into one level transition into
another is there some reason for that
oh goodness gravy yep this doesn't look
good is where I die oh well nothing
nothing
lots Cheers man I could fight off an
army with all these chairs I am
destroying the order get out of here
get out of here huh what do you think of
me now okay barrels Oh get out of here
messing your [ __ ] up oh yeah yeah yeah
here
Lamson not gonna like why cuz I waste
oil alright actually I'm gonna cut it
here thank you guys so much for watching
and I will see you in the next part
bye bye